uh hello everyone i'm the associate
director of
rnd department at greenwich china
i did my phd in germany and then
a postdoc in australia now i'm back in a
city called suzhou
while working for jinweed so
in today's presentation i will introduce
a nice trick
in genetic experiment which is using
long single string dna
as a donor for a knocking experiment
in this presentation i will go through
basically several aspects
in which scenario single stream dna
could be helpful
especially in comparison to double
strength dna
[Music]
then i will compare different methods
for its preparation
and our multiple approaches to ensure
the quality
of our single-strand dna and before
finally i reached the conclusion
of this talk
so for the interest of this audience i
guess most of people are of a genetic
background so we need to make a cup of
choice
before we execute a genetic experiment
okay so the first one is forward
genetics
versus reverse genetics if you are after
a clear phenotype
then go for forward genetics such as the
random neutrogena screening
using sgin library also in the scope of
crispr
then identify the genetic element
underlying the phenotype
on the other hand if you don't have a
clear phenotype but a clear genetic
element to target
normally you get the knowledge from
previous study or bioinformatic work
then you go for reverse genetics for
that
you also have two choices then one is
precise the other is
random manipulation of your genome
if you insert your genetic element
randomly into the genome
it's easier to achieve but it comes with
the risk
of several aspects such as multiple copy
insertion
disruption of endogenous functional
elements where the insertion is
taking place in addition the inserted
element itself may be subject to virus
levels of local genetic regulation
so for a more reproducible way
i would recommend we always do a precise
genetic editing
we precisely insert our
segment of interest into the genomic
location
at precessive one where we want
[Music]
or we can make a deletion or point
mutation uh this can all be considered
as a special type of insertion or from
this point on i record a knocking
experiment
this will be the focus of our talk today
so okay we have decided that we want to
do a precise insertion
or a locking experiment and then we also
face
two choice one is shall we generate a
double stream break or shall we do it
without a double chain break
in any case you need to design your
genetic element in a cassette where two
homology aren't
precisely matching the point where you
want to
insert into the genome the exogenous
sequence
which is in green here is flanked
between the two homology on
which is in the gray segment
later on we will actually give examples
that a break
normally greatly improve the efficiency
of the insertion
so the next decision is to
how to precise generate a break on the
target region
and previously there are some tools
using talent or thin finger which is
precisely
programmable protein module that can
recognize a given sequence
however the relationship between protein
modules and your nucleotide sequence is
not always a straightforward
the application is hence limited
people are turning into another much
simpler
our choice is the well-known crispr
system which
utilizes the rna protein complex to
achieve
sequence selectivity as i dn pairing is
precisely one or one this method become
a choice
and people go quickly so finally once we
decide we use
the crispr to generate double stream
break we still need to decide
how to deliver this component and what
form of template for repairing
so from this point on i will focus on
the repairing template
as you can see on this table
the first row is how we generate a
double string break dna break you can go
from no break at
all generate a finger break a nick on
your dna
or a double strand dna break and
the first column shows you what choice
of template we have
in case of no template it's well known
non-homologous
and join which leads to errors in
repairing
and normally a deletion
when we have template in the case
you still have choice such as single
string rna finger string dna
or double string dna so it's really
worthwhile to carefully consider
and explore all these possibilities
because different combinations
actually trigger different stereo
pathways for repair
which results in different efficiency
for knocking
and off target back for example
in the next few slides we will focus on
just comparing
two scenarios using double string dna
versus
finger chain dna when you generate a
double strand break
which is in the red rectangle in this
slide
so in the context of generating double
string
break by crispr and then we compare
single
string dna out performance the double
chin dna
in several scenarios those include
human peripheral blood cells or mice
not to mention the stair line the
knocking efficiency is
in general higher in various length of
things
being tested in addition it has been
reported that it's less toxic
to the host and show higher specificity
okay so much for the introduction in the
next few slides i will use some specific
examples to highlight the unique
advantage of single stream dna
for knocking before going
into specific cases i actually want to
emphasize that using single string dna
as the knocking template
is nothing but a new trick so it's
intuitive to come up with this idea
actually
because single string dna contains as
much in genetic
information establishing dna so as you
can see
on the left part of this table
in the early 80s even before we can
really generate double strain break in
eukaryotic cells
there were many studies testing
single-strand dna against double-strand
dna in terms of
knocking efficiency
as time goes by we use
tayden and then crisp
to generate double stream break and
single string dna has been used in many
organisms from
algae rice to mouse and even
non-human planet
okay so
many people especially who work with
mouse genetics has been doing
conditioning knock out or knocking
experiments
and this is how single chain dna
combined with crispr
has changed the way people generate mass
model
so previously the knocking is achieved
by
homologous recombination without double
strain break
in stem cells the stem cells has to be
screened
in vitro and then injected into the
embryo
at the black tomato stage
only some of those stem cells can grow
into
a genuine cell and then you can only
define
the genetic the genotype in the next
generation
so it's a year-long project
when the critical technique has been
introduced
crispr complex and the single or double
string dna can be injected into
fertilized
eggs and the genetic editing took place
immediately all the cells developed from
this egg contain the same modification
if it happened the process is left for
shortened to six months
there is no need for individual
screening
so um i will use
condition not experiment to illustrate
how long single chain dna make life
of researchers easier we all know
to construct a condition non-combined
this is actually a knocking experiment
where
two short log c sequence has to be
inserted into the axon
of the note called gene of interest
therefore they are intuitively very easy
to come up
that there are two ways to do this
both can start using two single string
two sgi to generate double string break
around the region where the log speed
sequence are to be incorporated
and then we have two choice we can use
two
short sequence with homology arms
to replace the original sequence so two
knocking with short sequence or we can
just use
one long single chain dna with a two log
speed
slide and as a repairman template
of course people have tried that those
methods have been tested
and different efficiency has been
reported
so we just list the relevant key papers
for
the interest of our audience
in case of one long repealing template
especially lows highlight in red the
efficient can be as
high as 50
now we switch to another example how
you modify a peripheral immune cell
in this case a recent publication shows
that the efficiency of single-chain dna
is similar
or even higher than double-strand dna
more importantly the cells are more
tolerant to high concentration of single
stream dna
as you can see on the lower left part of
the graph
the dose of the repairing template is
increased
while the toxicity is not observed
for single chain dna
i want to highlight the advantage of
specificities of single string dna
so it's well known that even without any
crispr or double string
dna substring break
a repairing template such as double
string dna
can be randomly incorporated into adreno
which you can see
in the graph here the panel d
the most left column
so there are some random incorporations
of double string dna without any other
components of the crispr system
and when you generate a double string
break using crystal system but with an
off-target
sgi so somewhere uh not related to your
homology and
the incorporation of double chin dna
into a genome is even higher
but single stranding is still
demonstrating
a very low random insertion in this case
so i would say in this case that
knocking efficiency between double and
single string dna is not
different so dramatically and
here is a case where we have to focus on
other aspects such as toxicity or
specificity
when we're considering the template for
repairing
so our users
our customers actually design the single
stream dna and
order it from us in some cases we will
be asked
for advices on how to design the single
string dna for knocking experiment
well i always said in general
you can use shorter homology on for
single strain dna
compared to double strand repairing
template
but the optimal length here is context
dependent
i will just leave some reference here
for how to design a single string dna
i would advise that the reported values
can at
best serve as a starting point for your
optimization
because it's really depending on your
gene the location of insertion
and the biological system you are using
in the next few slides i will give some
examples
some stamina papers where people
systematically compare
the relationship between the length of
the
homology arm and the gene of interest
for example in least one
they compared two kinds of insert a
very short one in the panel b and a
relatively long one
a gfp independent a and b and
uh then different lengths of homologous
ion is used
and in general the longer the higher
efficiency but your saturated at the
curtain level interesting to notice that
for example if you compare the same gene
to be inserted
rev11a in two different cell lines
the optimal homology eye is different
okay this is another good paper where
different design strategy is compared
for the single string dna
so you can see that the efficiency is
higher when the single stream dna
sequence is designed
to be the same strength as what the sgi
target
especially in the lower part of the
graph
okay and the single screen dna is skewed
to the upstream of the cut generated by
the sgi
in this case the efficiency will be
better
similar suggestions were given in this
paper published a year later
follow the length of the homolog
is not solely investigated so the
researchers jumped from
tens of bases quickly to hundreds of
places
without fully explored the room in
between
nevertheless a few good
advice is given and
i just want to emphasize that the sgi
targeting strength
is found to be less relevant for
efficiency in this case
again highlighting what i just said
you have really have to optimize your
system
and it looks like the cells
took different mechanisms to repair
a double string break in different
scenarios
so up to now i hope
i have convinced you that single string
being is
quite advantageous in some knocking
experiments
over double stream dna so the immediate
question
is how should we prepare it okay so
there are three major rules for
preparation
chemical ones pcr based methods
and knickers bases method i'm going
through them
one by one so when you consider short as
ssdna when it's shorter than 200 nuclear
types
it's essentially the same oligos we
ordered
for our pcr reaction it's very cheap
we think this is fast but as you know
the oligos is synthesized by chemical
methods by adding
one dntp at the time so the efficiency
is not 100
as the length goes up there is always a
chance that
a dntp will be dropped at some point
and that's why you cannot reach
more than 200 and t in general
so for longer single string dna we have
to turn to molecular biology
okay for longer one and for a better
quality
so there are actually four types of
pcr based methods i'm going through them
two at the time
in a slide the first one is reverse
transcription
okay so first you need a double string
dna template
but just reverse transcribe one into
mrna
then the mrna is purified and
reverse transcribed back to single
string dna
okay in theory it will work
exonuclear experiment is
similar in a design but going for
another angle
so again you have two primers but
only one primer is phosphorylated during
pcr
uh then exonuclear is added
it prefers phosphorylated fiber n so if
you only digest
the one with a fibroid phosphorylated n
which is the red strain in the right
part of this presentation
and of course the gray one
is left which is the single stranding a
you want
in series
uh the next two pcr based method is
shown here
first one using a magnetic bit just to
specifically pull down
one type of one strain of
dna during synthesis
normally it's a shared evidence biotin
pair
and what is left in the sugar native
is your designated single stream dna
asymmetry pcr
is very straightforward so you add two
parameters in your pci reaction
one type of premise in except and
of course you end up with a population
dominated by one type of single-stream
dna
so i have introduced so far four types
of pcr based method to generate
fingerstring dna and
the pros all of them is that they are
quite cheap
okay the kong are server
pcr is not straightforward for difficult
template
okay sometimes you have to case by case
optimize the condition
and there are errors introduced by the
polymers
especially if you're doing a reverse
transcription
then you have a problem with the
template of double string dna okay
so you want to remove the template of
double chain dna in your final product
otherwise it will be difficult to
interpret with your experiment with that
if you see an insertion a random
insertion is it caused by the
single-strand dna or is it caused by the
residual double chin dna in my soul
called
single-chain dna sample right
when you are using exonuclear method
you try to remove just one strain but
the
nuclei is not as selective as you think
okay you always have some inconvenient
digestive strain
and this is even more severe with smh
pcr because
by definition you will have some
product from the other primer which is
not dominating
so now we can turn to a
method we recommend which is using a
leaking enzyme
also called sneaker this is a special
restriction
enzyme which only generates a single
stream break
so the sequence targeted single string
sequence
we end at is first into a specific
vector
the vector is flanked with the knickers
recognized sequence
at least on one side okay so
after a single colony is verified by
sanger the plasmid is subject
to maxi prep and then restriction enzyme
digestion
at one end uh you have to generate the
single string break
by knicker on the other hand and it's
more free
so you can either generate a single
string or double string break
in any case a single chain dna which is
what you want
can be dissociated from this plasmid
and geo purify this is actually the
method of choice
by drinkwith in producing our signature
dna
because our product is derived from one
clone
and can be sequenced by sanger both
before and after
the java purification so
the another one advantage is that the
process also minimizes
endotoxin because of the electrophoresis
process
and in principle it should not contain
any double chin dna
we will control the qc reduction soon to
prove that
okay here we have introduced the pros
and cons for all six methods
um it actually are up to you to choose
but we believe that
in terms of quality making enzyme-based
methods
is bad while in other scenarios you may
choose other methods if cost or timing
is your primary concern
okay as we have said uh how do we ensure
the quality of single-stranding
what we are going to look at first we
have to make sure the endotoxins should
be minimized
because it's detrimental to cell culture
and micro-injection
and the sequence integrity is also a
major concern
when we generate double chin break in a
cell and use
a template to repair it there always
will be some
errors when the cell use the repelling
machinery to repair the rate so
if we see some uh mutation
in our final product how do we know it's
introduced by the
repairing process or it was already
there in the pairing template
so as a single string dna provider at
least
we generally will make sure that the
template is as correct as possible
so the rest is done by the nature okay
um in this aspect we also cover that
make sure that there's no
uh establishing dna in the product
for the reason i just mentioned
so in addition to the cytotoxicity
result i showed you previously
on the t-cell paper
jimmy's also done some experiments with
our own cell culture so in this case
we use electrocorrelation
to manipulate two cell lines
and we electrocute excess amount of
single or double stream dna about 20
millimole per
million cell then the sale viability is
assessed
after 48 hours by commencing boosting
as you can see from the three
independent replica case
experiment the viability is always
higher
in case of single strain dna which is
orange
in this group it can also be seen
on the right for the image of the cell
okay so a question we often get is
how do you sequence the single string
dna
so as i said we always sequence the
plasmid before the
knickers and electrophoresis was applied
and in theory there shouldn't be any
mutation
by this case but we all always get some
feedback from customers they want to see
the
singularity of the sequencing of the
ssdn itself
so it's not so difficult except for the
query three point end as using the
single sequence
uh goes from five frame end to three
point n so
if you have a double strand that's not a
problem because both primers
can go in two directions but for single
string dna
um the very three part n can be
sequenced
okay so to address this question we
use a method highlight on the right
we first add an adapter to our single
chain dna product
it's a single string being ligation
experiment and then we convert
the single chain dna into a double
strand and then
we can use a primer to see the where we
represent the result can be seen in
this slide the first row
is a typical example of single
sequencing
stronger three chromatin itself the
first
few tens of nucleotides is not
visible by a traditional sender method
however if we add the adapter and
then we can see all the sequence in the
trigger end
which you can see in the lower part of
this graph
the region highlighted by green is the
sequence of the adapter
and the rest are the single-stranding we
produce
so this is a way we make 100 sure that
our single-stream dna from uh five-point
sharpness
as we design a nice thing about this
uh adding a adapter to a single stream
dna is that we can use the same material
and further convert it for a library
suitable for next generation sequencing
and in this way we can see the point
mutation rate
as necessary next generation sequencing
has a higher
sensitivity so in xenga normally
the resolution is about 10 percent so if
you have
one mutation out of let's say 20
molecules and may not be visible but
with ngs we can go very deep
in sequencing so i just show you example
about a 179
nt of single string dna prepared by
genres and
stand for ngs sequencing so
the coverage uh on the uh shown on the
top in the blue line
are as close as 200 okay
and the mutation rate is very high it's
about
0.02 it's actually not the mutation rate
it's a combination of permutation
and the theoretical sequencing error
rate
for the ngs because the sequence itself
also introduced
a certainty so this is as far as we can
get
less than 0.01
of point mutation could be even lower
because it's derived from single colony
so
as i said many of our customers are
concerned is there any double stream
being left
uh normally we prepare a qc result
where we subject the product to a s1
nuclear
so s1 new case is a single stream
specific endonuclease
and it only hydrates single-stranded dna
or rna
and if there are double strand being
left
in this sample it will be intact by the
s1 nuclear
so we normally show qc results
after applying s1 nucleus there is
nothing left
but the trace amount of s1 nucleus can
be
hard to detect so we designed this
experiment
specifically to address this question so
from then five to lane eight we add
double stream dna from 10 nano grain to
100 nano
so the 10 nano grain double cmd in
length 5
is almost invisible it's the resolution
detection limit of this job and then in
length 4 you can see that
we add 2 microgram of ssdna
plus s1 nuclei so all ssdna
is removed if there is any double
strength dna
left in this sample if b fainter than
the 10 nanogram of 78
so in this way we conclude the level of
double strength dna contamination is
less than 0.5 percent in our final
product
okay so we reach to our conclusion we
hope
during this talk you are more familiar
and convinced with single strength
great potential in assisting your
knocking experiment
and whenever you design experiment with
double stream dna think about using as a
dna as
an alternative we have also carefully
compared the methods for producing
single chain dna
and which in which chose nikon's method
as we value our product quality the most
thanks again for your time and i hope
you have found some
helpful information